as the two conservative leadership
candidates continue to talk about giving
out countless billions in cash as if
they were hosting a warped version of
supermarket sweep the Labor Party has
quietly and frightening ly been
exploring other economic initiatives one
of which is a lifetime gifts tax under
this you would pay tax on everything
your parents gave you while alive or
after they die over the value of 125,000
pounds this presumably means we must
keep a tab on all the gifts we get from
mum and dad down the years plus any cash
handouts when we get married or buy our
first house or car possibly even when
mum buys you a coffee at the shops as
well the current inheritance tax system
is iniquitous enough but this idea the
state can help itself to whatever it
chooses is evil and destroys enterprise
seeking to leave something to your
children is a basic human instinct this
is straight out of the Hugo Chavez
playbook in Venezuela and we all know
what happened there okay so let's look
at what genre done all the shadow towns
that actually said one report that
you've commissioned land for the many it
says that it would recommend and
scrapping inheritance tax and replacing
it with like a lifetime gifts times that
you're trying to do that I do we're
looking at it and it might be one of
those ideas and we're consulting on at
the moment the age of interest I think
it's interesting we need to have a
fairer system of how we can ensure that
wealth is more fairly distributed that's
one idea
yes we're listening we're listening to a
whole range of ideas so my view is I
mean that was Sophie Ridge on Sunday
with John McDonald and my view is as it
currently stands it's three hundred and
twenty five thousand pounds that you can
leave without tax and that is more than
enough to set somebody up quite
comfortably so I whether or not I'd go
the full way is what Ramadan is
suggesting here I can't say for sure but
definitely we have a sick with the
levels of inequality we have in this
country but there are people record
numbers of people using food banks the
need to redistribute wealth is
the comb at this point so you steal it
from other people well taxes are one set
one pays taxes yeah but hold on my
friend for the purpose of debate husband
and wife put a business together they
make for the purpose of debate three
million quid whatever it might be and
they've got a decent house so you're
allowing them the two hundred three
hundred and twenty five or whatever the
rest the state just taxes a massive
amounts does it raise taxes to attack us
to a certain extent yeah bonus suits in
red so I I don't I don't think this is
uh probably a I don't think this is
gonna work one of the middle zeros one
of the reasons is it hits so many
homeowners in one hundred and
twenty-five thousand pounds when you
look at property prices in the Southeast
of England it's gonna hit pretty this
year in place right so I think it's
gonna be a huge vote loser for the Labor
Party which today it's been revealed has
polling the lowest it has in its entire
history all holy history colleges it's
the 40s the forties right so but III do
think when I looked into this I do think
there is a genuine bubble we need to
look at and that is the inheritance
bubble that is looming so the baby
boomers being the richest generation in
in history right will eventually pass
down that wealth to the Millennials who
are currently very poor now part of the
problem is the Millennials won't inherit
that until they're all in their mid-60s
so we've got a big inheritance bumble a
bit like the housing bubble and what
this policy was attempting to address
was that problem and how how does that
relate to inequality I don't think
they've got the answer right but it is
definitely worth examining because it's
a question that needs an answer
sure well I'm getting really frustrated
with this policy I know I know I nearly
made a really inappropriate
three strikes you're out I know I am
getting really frustrated but these
these visions about taking off people to
give to people instead of encouraging
people to create their own wealth and
opportunity and if you talk about you
know you can give around 125,000 pounds
to a child well good luck with that
because most people if they've worked
hard and then they need social care they
would have had to a property sold that
house to fund their own care in the best
part and it's it's frustrating to me
because what I want is a situation where
we are encouraging people work hard
create some wealth if you want to pass
your wealth down to your children then
do so and I feel like we're going into a
direction of see that millionaire over
there that the lady is ruthless point
that way yeah sometimes I work four
hours a day many many hours often for
very little reward never enjoyed of the
people they've paid taxes he's a
horrible person because he's got all
that money to take it off him and give
it to that person that hs4 palek
politics have ever been frustrated
thought about stealing from people who
deserve it more it's about recognizing
that there are people who have less who
might deserve it just as much I mean
people who I mean I first I'm personally
quite privileged I was boy I was born in
Darlington but my parent my parents are
both doctors and were able to give me a
great school and I had all the
opportunities like a want in life but
somebody just three doors down the road
also in Darlington living in a countless
they would have nowhere near wise you
want to let that down and not bring up
let's not level down let's bring up to
support the mechanisms of doing it the
levers the state has at its disposal in
order to equalize what is a very unequal
society at the moment and I speak as a
young baby boomer I think but you know I
recognize I've had peak almost
everything from peak oil peak publishing
you know both in print and in newspapers
and books and property I've heard
private education you know I've had
you've been kicked out of some of the
best schools in the room and having
settled that what I was given was all
those advantages I've never actually
been given any money
yet look forward and I'm not actually
expecting any money so if some part of
me agrees and Michelle too many children
I think people can pull themselves up by
their bootstraps that is not the case
anymore we do not have the ladder of
opportunity that we have we don't have
grammar schools me precisely we don't
have the social mobility sort of access
that we that we have let me do you agree
grammar schools you know can we just
talk about the inheritance tax system at
the moment which is that married couples
or civilly partnered couples can hand
down to their descendants or whoever
they like nine hundred and fifty
thousand pounds which it's almost a
million quid and after that their
inheritors have to pay 40 percent
inheritance tax so I think that as it
stands at the moment I think to be fair
what hardly anyone pays that right so
about four percent five yeah well good
because actually if you're if you're
poor you don't have it if you're rich
rich rich you can avoid it and actually
it's the middle as usual that bears the
brunt of this tax so so it's not really
addressing the point families concern
about nor the point that kind of the
general philosophy I raised which is
there will be a bubble and what do we do
with that
I think Rachael tell me already the
interesting your view I think which made
a really good point grammar schools
where I think a tremendous a tool of
social mobility I think in the past
majid you've said that you're a support
or your supporter of the grammar
it changed my life I got expelled from
further education college and my mum put
me in a grand fits it's three Michelle I
would imagine your for them yeah yeah
where are you on grammar schools I'm in
two minds because yes because well I
went to a mixture of State in private
and but with live with grammar schools
yes as the benefit of kids who are
naturally gifted or kids who who are
particularly hard they might they may
have that extra ladder but at the same
time the housing around grammar schools
automatically becomes more expensive
because it's because it's nearby and
therefore you create that more elitist
system why don't you guys think that
these days that they're the the
government has asked grammar schools to
actually have certain policies in place
that allow for working-class kids to
come in and and make sure that they
allocate those spaces to them and so I
think there's a lot more to be done most
certainly if you have the caveats there
that those grammar schools must reach
out to work in class communities then it
can
it can really change someone's life I
never went to private school I've been
state school and State University all my
life State University University of
London I should say but but actually
that two years I spent in grammar school
changed my educational history I was
pretty much by all definitions a failing
student before that point and then ended
up getting external test it's 125
thousand I mean that would get put maybe
give you a deposit on a house in London
this certainly wouldn't matter for life
your whole house in whole very much my
problem one of the biggest issues facing
this country right now is regional
inequality you can see where the brexit
vote is based on whether the least
social mobility and fixing that problem
means investing in those areas fixing
infrastructure facing trafficking
transport but the state needs the money
to do that we all work in jobs we Lowe's
for buses we despise with colleagues we
hate we do it all our lives if we can't
do it at the end of it we never see our
children from Nativity to graduation
because we're all working our nuts off
if I can't even leave them my house
what's the bloody point yeah because
there are people who have nothing